I read this character and I went okay I
said this is fun I said do you mind Ben
I want to play this character I said I
want to have fat hands and I want to
dance
[Applause]
and he looked at me he's like what I
take dance classes and I took hip-hop
classes and then what I'll find is I'll
find a character to put that with so I
said look I just I don't know what to
say like sometimes with a character you
just get an instinct on what you want to
do and I I just know I really want bad
hands I'm going to dance okay flaming
Dragon face first take a big step
back and literally your own face he
said look are you sure you can you why
you just be you it just looks at me like
uh you know that Ben look we're like
okay like I don't know what is it what
what's happening here yeah yeah yeah he
created the makeup and we did the makeup
test he was like he like he picked the
music out he edited this thing together
he was just pissing himself he sent it
to me he's like okay I get it I get it
yeah yeah